ils sont arrivés en métropole il y a 2
semaines et après un passage par Exen
Provence ils ont rejoint les environs de
Paris où ils ont fini leur entraînement
logés dans une caserne militaire de
jouillant Josas le grand jour est arrivé
levé tau les pompiers de la Réunion
entourés de pompiers venus des autres
d'hommes ont choisi de procéder à une
cérémonie en hommage au pompiers tué la
veille en combattant un incendie dans
les pyénes
orientalesous
[Musique]
lors du départ à sonn il est enfin temps
de rejoindre la capitale les dernières
consignes sont donné c'est 10 de la
Réunion qui coordonne le bataillon c'est
vous qui venez plus loin donc il faut
qu'il vous entend il faut qu'il vous
VO
ok c'est bien voilà et je voir sourir
sur V visag plus dur fait maintenant ça
vatre une promen de
santéentraînement non vous l'avez donc
il faut y aller drapau et la G ok
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout cette année
c'est un pompier réunionné qui a
l'honneur de porter le drapeau du 9e
bataillon des sapeurs pompiers de France
qui regroupe tous les sapeurs pompiers
des DOM honneur au drapeau donc voyez
que c'est déjà de l'émotion c'est déjà
des sensations fortes alors je je me
pose la question comment ça sera sur les
champs mais sinon c'est fantastique
aventure humaine super super en plus on
pas partage ça avec les autres collègues
des DOM donc c'est super super tous
ensemble ils monent dans les bus qui les
conduisent sur les Champs-Élysées
pendant le trajet certains font le vide
en eux se reposent pendant que d'autres
font briller leur casques en arrivant
devant l'Arc de Triomphe où presque deux
siècles d'histoire les contemple la
tension grimpe l'image est saisissante
de la descente de l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées entouré de charard
d'assaut émane une impression quelque
peu particulière les pompiers réunionnés
affinent maintenant les derniers détails
de leurs uniformes tout doit être
parfait mais avant tout c'est un
sentiment de fierté qui domine on va
être honnête c'était fatiguant tout le
monde est au bout et là c'est la fin
mais c'est la joie parce que on a
travaillé dur et on va montrer ce qu'on
sait faire et on va donner tout ce qu'il
faut quoi le bonheur la joie la fierté
et l'honneur mais vraiment un grand
honneur quoi être sur la plus belle
avenue du monde je crois que c'est pas
donné à tout le monde et là c'est un
rêve qui se réalise le défilé ne
commencera que dans quelques heures mais
il faut penser à prendre toutes les
précautions
on se prépare séance
[Musique]
pipi l'heure est encore à la
convivialité un rapide petit- déjeuner
est pris afin de donner des forces
suffisantes pour défiler car sous la
chaleur de ce 14 juillet il en faudra
c'est le petit déjeuner qu'on a pas eu
donc là on est en train de manger avant
de pouvoir marcher sur les champ éisé
ils vont arpenter les pavés jusqu'à midi
quelques photos souvenir avant de
défiler devant la nation les officiels
notamment le ministre de l'Intérieur
viennent saluer les troupes et en
profite pour les questionner peu avant
le départ les photographes se pressent
pour immortaliser l'instant certains
accordent une interview au journaliste
dans le public des enfants mais aussi
des réunionnés sont venus tôt pour
soutenir ces saports
pompiers le fait de participer au défilé
de voir toutes les troupes défilées et
aussi j'ai mon frère qui participe qui
participe au défilé quelques minutes
avant le départ l'excitation est
palpable c'est comme avant une course à
pied on est on a beaucoup d'adrénaline
qui monte et on est on a envie de partir
être fier d'être à Paris aujourd'hui
pour montrer que la Réunion aussi on a
des pompiers compétents et fiers d'être
pompiers comme si j'étais un gamin en
fait un tout petit gamin comme devant un
jouet et on est tout excité et on a hâte
de défiler sur les Champs-Élysées c'est
des millions de personnes qui vont nous
regarder et notamment tous les DomTom
qui vont nous regarder aussi ils on un
très attentif sur notre prestation et on
a hâte de de montrer justement que si on
est là on est pas on est là parce qu'on
l' mérité et aussi pour représenter les
DOM TOM et les sapeurs pompiers de
France grande fierté grande fierté pour
tout le tous les pompiers de France pour
tous le département de Guadeloupe
notamment et tous les pompiers de TR
très heureux d'être ici le défilé peut
démarrer la plus belle avenue du monde
s'ouvre au 83 sapeur Pompi le P cadansé
le public applaudit la descente vers la
tribune présidentielle se fait en bon
ordre tout est parfaitement
la nation les regarde la fierté demeure
on essaie de faire le vide en fin de
compte on essaie de faire le vide et
d'écouter la musique être dans son être
bien dans son rythme puis cé un grand
plaisir pour nous en tout cas en tout
cas pour moi d'être venu ici et de
représenter notre île au champsélysé
devant le président de la République et
aussi le peuple parisien qui nous a très
haut acclamé il y a beaucoup de tension
qui sont qui sont lâché et jeis dire que
c'est éta j'ai trouvé sa cour en fait j'
redemande encore en fait mais très
émouvant extrêmement émouvant surtout
lors du
passage des des mirages et avec le
drapeau bleu blanc rouge et notamment
lorsquon arrive vers l'avenue de Marini
et qu'on voit la tribune présidentielle
là c'est vraiment très émouvant on peut
qu'apprécier le défilé se finit déjà il
est temps de repartir
[Musique]